[Musique]
en
bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue
pour ce forum des parlementaires
c'est un rendez vous traditionnel pour
nos universités de rentrée cette année
en virtuel pour cette cité démocrate
suis très heureux de vous accueillir
merci à tous les participants
merci à nos parlementaires qui sont déjà
arrivées qui sont assez nombreux merci à
toutes celles et ceux qui organisent
aussi tout ça depuis maintenant pas mal
d'heures on voit se dérouler et tables
rondes des ateliers des conversations
extrêmement intéressante avec des
internautes nombreux donc merci à toute
l'équipe qui pilote cet événement donc
je vais avoir le plaisir d'animer ce
forum avec nos parlementaires donc forum
des parlementaires on a comme vous le
savez la chance de compter des groupes
vont à l'assemblée nationale solide qui
s'est renforcée on va y revenir et
sénateurs également dans certains
renouvellements dans une semaine
et évidemment on n'a pas toujours connu
les périodes où les parlementaires
étaient nombreux donc pour ceux qui sont
là depuis quelques années c'est
évidemment important pour notre famille
politique
or en et gazon c'est à dire qu'on va
organiser une conversation assez libre
où on va on va rebondir sur les sujets
d'actualité
objectif c'est évidemment de parler de
l'actualité nationale parler des lois
passées présentes si possible et surtout
futur avec nos parlementaires et
notamment sans doute abordé les travaux
de la fin du quinquennat qui sont des
travaux particulièrement important et
attendu je crois par les françaises et
les français pour introduire ce débat
premier sujet bien évidemment on a
beaucoup parlé de notre groupe modem et
apparentés à l'assemblée nationale ces
dernières semaines et pour cause
le groupe modem a accumulé des renforts
à l'assemblée nationale avec des députés
venus de la majorité mais aussi venues
de l'opposition qui ont rejoint les
rangs de notre groupe
ce fut particulièrement mis en avant
lors des journées parlementaires à
biscarrosse et à sanguinet alors
évidemment première question pour pour
patrick mignola président du groupe et
député de savoie
alors combien de députés cantonaux c'est
trivial mais on est mal les forces de
notre monde aujourd'hui mais c'est pas
non plus les chiffres qui fait la force
aussi je voudrais patrick que tu me
dises un peu comment tu vois ma place du
groupe
dorénavant dans la majorité
présidentielle est dans le paysage
politique français
merci fait bien et grand salut à à tous
mes collègues
bravo pour ce petit film vous et qu'ils
ont réalisé ce qui nous échappe sera pas
comme vous le constatez sinon parce que
nous avons des parlementaires qui sont
beaux mais je crois surtout que si
s'étendent
c'est parce qu'elle est belle patrick
est belle la nanon moi c'est vrai
c'était un générique le masculin
l'emporté sur le féminin ce qui est
absolument déplorable
richard a parfaitement raison non je
crois que c'est le seul salut mythe et
qui est attractive
je crois que c'est françois qui
défaillent personnes deux jours
effectivement le rôle de notre groupe
changer de nature puisque nous allier de
la république en marche ayant perdu la
majorité absolue
assez naturellement nous sommes revêtu
d'une responsabilité particulière cette
veillée parce que ce quinquennat dure
cinq ans mais parfois on dit que l'amour
dure trois ans moi je suis de ceux qui
pensent que l'amour peut durer plus que
trois ans mais il ya une chose dont je
suis sûr c'est que si les canadiens du
présent dans notre pays
évidemment ça peut pas marcher or le
quinquennat sarkozy s'était mal fini
dans les haies compétition assez néfaste
entre copé et fillon
le quinquennat hollande on se rappelle
avait mal fini aussi avec les frondeurs
nous notre responsabilité
et c'est ça que nous avons en tête 7
veiller à ce que jusqu'à la dernière
heure du dernier jour la majorité
parlementaire reste au service du pays
qui reste au service en fait du projet
qui nous a conduits aux responsabilités
alors comment on le fait on le fait avec
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de sérieux et
je veux rendre hommage à chaque député
du groupe qui depuis trois ans a montré
alors que la plupart d'entre nous
étaient des néo députés même si parfois
il avait accumulé des expériences
locales
ils ont d'abord montré beaucoup de
beaucoup de sérieux
pas de de calcul florentin une entrée
systématique dans les textes avec je
crois une notion de l'intérêt général
et puis on le fait avec beaucoup
d'unités parce que dans ce groupe comme
dans tous les autres règne la liberté de
vote
mais chez nous c'est probablement encore
plus vrai qu ailleurs sauf qu'on sait
conjuguer la liberté parce que chacun
doit être mue par son intime conviction
et l'unité à chaque fois que l'essentiel
est en jeu et en particulier quand il y
a des engagements ils sont ceux de cette
famille politique
ou quand il ya besoin de solidifier la
majorité alors effectivement cette unité
nous a rendus attractifs puisque un
certain nombre de députés nous ont
rejoint et fabien tu as eu raison de
souligner que des députés de la majorité
nous ont rejoints et secours sis qui
étaient partis ou en partance de la
république en marche mais le fond
l'objectif était pas celui là parce que
quand nous avons décidé peu après le
remaniement ministériel d'ouvrir le
groupe de l'élargir l'objectif était
bien sûr que ce soit pas seulement un
élargissement du groupe modem
mais que ce soit un élargissement de la
majorité tout entière et donc nous avons
déjà député issu de l'opposition n'a
rejoint qu'est sabine tirer et nous
aurons allez on va dire au moins autant
la semaine prochaine qui nous
rejoindront
issue de l'opposition art sur des bases
claires c'est à dire que nous faisons
partie de la majorité
nous avons nous aurons la même stratégie
aux élections régionales nous
soutiendront le même candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
emmanuel macron et nous vivrons dans le
cadre de cette liberté de vote mais
également de cette exigence de liens
entre nous pour que lorsque nous ne
sommes pas d'accord nous sachions
lorsque l'essentiel était en jeu
assurer l'unité parce qu'au fond le but
c'est très bien de se dire pour nous
quand on au modem évidemment que le
groupe qui faisait 45 des budgets va
passer cinq ans
et puis passera peut-être 60 le but ce
n'est pas de faire du nombre du nombre
qui l'a très bien dit c'est surtout de
se demander à quoi ça sert
et dans les temps qui viennent notre
responsabilité c'est d'apporter des
réponses aux français dans tous les
sujets qui sont ceux de leurs
inquiétudes leurs inquiétudes et d'abord
sanitaires l es économique et social et
tout ceci
dedans un dans un fond sociétal que
celui de l'urgence climatique et donc on
va travailler à fond sur le plan de
relance pour savoir où est la boussole
du juste qu'est ce qu'on fait en termes
de partage de la valeur
qu'est ce qu'on fait en matière
d'urgence climatique qu'est ce qu'on
fait en matière de travail territoriales
pour réconcilier les territoires qu'on a
troupe opposé les oppositions à
l'assemblée en particulier depuis le
début de ce quinquennat
et puis il faut qu'on puisse répondre au
delà même du plan de relance à 2 vaste
sujet qui se consolait des mois qui
viennent et qui sont aussi des sujets
d'inquiétude pour les français c'est la
question régaliennes
la question de la sécurité la question
du communautarisme la question
séparatisme on aura une loi sur le
séparatisme parce que vivre français
c'est vivre différents c'est bien vivre
dans la même république est dans la même
nation et puis il y aura la question de
la dépendance et on a la grande loi sur
la dépendance qui arrivera d'ici la fin
de l'année parce qu'on sait qu'un des
grands changements sociétaux auquel ce
quinquennat doit répondre c'est c'est le
vieillissement de la population c'est
pas très joli c'est considérer que quand
on vit jeunes un peu plus longtemps et
qu'en tous cas dans ces derniers jours
deux
vie forcément on bouscule les familles
les budgets et que et que pour une
société
je crois que la valeur se mesure à la
façon de traiter les plus fragiles
c'est le cas avec les tout jeunes c'est
le cas avec les personnes en situation
de handicap ça doit être le cas aussi
avec le les personnes les plus âgées est
en situation de dépendance voilà c'est
ça l'objectif
soyons plus grand pour être plus fort
dans la majorité et surtout pour que la
politique que nous conduisons et
toujours cette obsession du sud merci
merci beaucoup patrick avant de passer
aux sujets de fond qui a osé un chapeau
parfait avec tous les sujets qu'on va on
va aborder mais on parle beaucoup du
groupe est président de groupe en a
aussi parlé d'un intergroupe de maison
commune
l'intergroupe c'est la maison de commune
comment les choses vont s'articuler ce
qui aura un intergroupe je pense que
c'est intéressant de nous le dire à ce
stade voit le latéral gauche de l'as v
je l'avais appelé de mes voeux il ya
deux ans quand j'avais l'honneur de
succéder à marc grâce à la confiance de
mes collègues parce que je trouvais
utile de montrer que la majorité n'était
pas une majorité de parti unique le
parti unique la gauche a essayé la
droite a essayé on sait comment sa fille
il faut montrer que voilà notre majorité
les solide parce qu'elle s'appuie sur
des tendances différentes il ya le
mouvement naturellement issu du parti du
président de la république il ya le
centre historique cette grande famille
des modes des démocrates que nous
représentons il ya aussi toutes celles
et ceux qui nous sont accompagnés et qui
sont susceptibles de nous rejoindre
je pense à des personnes venues du
centre beau jeu vous avez vu que en ce
moment même se réunissent les amis tu
arrives le drian et olivier hotte du
centre-droit françois intervenez tout à
l'heure lors des universités d'été de
agir mais le interview que c'est quoi
faut pas imaginer un achat d une sorte
de super structure en fait il s'agit
avant tout du rassemblement de tous les
groupes qui se sentent dans la majorité
présidentielle à l'assemblée nationale
c'est à dire qu'on soit capable de
resserrer les liens en se voyant
régulièrement c'est-à-dire que l'on
formalisé un opus
ce qu'on faisait jusqu'à présent
c'est-à-dire la coordination entre nous
deux rondes que les responsabilités qui
sont octroyés aux parlementaires de la
majorité soit mieux répartie en effet
entre nous donc chaque chaque courant de
pensée soit respectée en tant que tel et
puis et puis de se dire que quand on a
des difficultés parce que la semaine
prochaine par exemple on aura la loi sur
les néonicotinoïdes et la betterave et
ben on soit capable de se parler de se
dire quand on est d'accord de dire
éventuellement quand on n'est pas
d'accord en tout cas qui est pas de
surprise donc ne pas faire une structure
pour une structure parce que parce que
la maison commune c'est moi un état
d'esprit c'est moi une architecture
qu'un état d'esprit il faut que dans
l'état d'esprit on fasse travailler tout
le monde ensemble à 18 mois de la fin de
la législature il serait pas forcément
utile de mettre en place de la solution
merci beaucoup patrick on a rentré dans
les sujets c'est je crois le plus
intéressant avec avec nos parlementaires
on va commencer par l'économique et le
plan de relance je vais interroger jean
noël barrot et et philippe boulot sur ce
sujet là je pense que personne ne remet
en cause la l'ampleur et l'ambition du
plan de relance qui a qui a été proposé
par le par le gouvernement 100 milliards
ce n'est pas rien et vous rappeler
régulièrement nos parlementaires qui lie
à l'argent du plan de relance mais il ya
aussi les parrainent des français qui
est un enjeu et je voudrais demander à
jean noël au fond comment on fait pour
que ce plan de relance puissent
s'appliquer dans des délais rapides
correspondant aussi aux besoins
économiques pour éviter la casse
partiellement et aussi qu'il puisse
toucher tous les territoires je crois
que les questions qu'on entend
aujourd'hui son de cet ordre là la
question du timing
puis la question de l'adaptation du plan
à tous les territoires
peut-être qu ensuite philippe boulot
pour aller illustré par des exemples
peut-être dans sa circonscription je
sais qu'il a fait un travail aussi d'
enquête auprès des acteurs économiques à
quelques mois donc peut-être qu'une
réponse à deux voix sur ce sujet nous
intéresse
jean noël merci
beaucoup fabien et je rejoins tout à
fait ce ce que disait patrick au sujet
de ce plan de relance il faudra trouver
la juste boussole ou la boussole du
juste à la fois dans notre capacité à
défendre le principe d'un meilleur
partage du toner mais aussi de
s'intéresser à à la portée de ce plan là
dans nos territoires
on va découvrir le la traduction
législative de ce plan de relance
lundi 28 et à ce moment là nous aurons
la responsabilité l'assemblée nationale
de le discuter
éventuellement de l'amendé et cette
question là étaient au coeur des
journées parlementaires organisées par
le groupe
à l'initiative de patrick qui nous a
demandé notamment à jean paul et et à
moi pour le volet un peu plus économique
et financier puis à nos collègues qui
ont travaillé sur les questions de
transition écologique d'animer des
séances de travail qui était de file et
qui vont nous permettre de faire un
certain nombre de je crois que il ya
dans ce que dans la question que tu
poses ça bien un élément qui est
fondamental qui est la rapidité et la
territorialisation des choses
moi j'ai vu un implant j'ai vu france
relance qui qui me paraît par son
ampleur par ses priorités je rappelle
l'indépendance la transition écologique
et puis la cohésion donc les priorités
sont les bonnes c'est un plan qui qui va
faire l'objet d'un suivi très régulier
de la part de diverses instances place
et du plus haut niveau de l'état jusque
au niveau des territoires
mais reste à savoir comment on va
fonctionner la tuyauterie et comme
député des yvelines par exemple je ne
suis pas encore tout à fait au clair sur
la manière dont je peux accompagner les
acteurs de ma circonscription de mon
territoire dans la mobilisation de ce
plan de relance alors évidemment il ya
des mesures qui sont je dirais des
mesures de guichet qui sont déjà bien
connues pour certaines par les
entreprises l'activité partielle de
longue durée qui est un bloc
significative de ce plan et est un est
un dispositif que les entreprises
commencent à connaître la baisse des
impôts de production elle se fera de
manière assez automatiques
mais il y a énormément de choses dans le
domaine de la transition écologique pour
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics notamment en matière de mobilité
en matière de de limitation de
l'artificialisation des sols dont je ne
sais pas encore te dire la manière dont
nous pouvons faire l'articulation avec
le terrain et je dois dire que nous
avons pris goût à cette articulation
pendant la crise du colis depuis ce que
je crois qu ont été nombreux dans le
groupe à a joué un rôle important de
courroie de transmission entre les
administrations entre les ministères et
le terrain à la fois pour faire
connaître les mesures de soutien aux
acteurs de nos territoires et aussi pour
faire remonter les dysfonctionnements
éventuels
donc je crois qu'on aura vraiment un cas
que cela puisse être le cas du plan de
relance alors peut-être pour faire la
transition avec filipe bole au député du
maine-et-loire je crois que au moins 2 2
mais tu as fait une enquête un petit peu
avec quelque 400 acteurs économiques
dans ton territoire et je pense qu
évidemment ça ça nourrit aussi le
travail sur l'application du plan de
relance
oui bonsoir merci et effectivement dans
ce travail il a été effectué par ce
qu'il fallait à un moment donné mesurer
quel était l'état des troupes quelles
étaient les conséquences de cette
épidémie de ce qu'on finance / sur les
entreprises donc c'était sauf départ
mais si vous voulez là l'intérêt pour
nous parlementaires d'aller au contact
du terrain d'avoir une organisation qui
nous permet d'écouter ce qui se passe
sur les territoires s'agisse du plan de
relance d'autres sujets c'est justement
après de nouer des liens de confiance
avec les acteurs concernés qui
aujourd'hui sur l'incapacité en écho aux
grandes orientations de l'information
une décision et peuvent penser imaginer
deux relances de nous faire remonter les
idées donc c'est en cela aussi qu'on
sera en capacité de d'interagir sur les
textes qui nous seront présentés et je
crois qu'il faut aussi signaler que le
plan de relance est une chose mais qu'il
ya d'autres outils qui vont être
mobilisés et ainsi bien de terminer la
semaine dernière l'examen en commission
en première lecture à l'assemblée du
projet d'oise pas apte pour accélération
et simplification de l'action publique
et dont le titre deux concernait
justement un ensemble de dispositions
qui vont permettre dans l'industrie
française de d'accélérer d'avoir des
procédures simplifiées ce qui nous
permettra remettre en place et de
pouvoir faciliter le développement d'une
industrie qui nous rendra plus
souveraine dans les différents secteurs
tel qu'on a pu voir les difficultés
rencontrées pendant la crise dans le
secteur du médicament
le secteur de l'industrie donc on vous
dira que voyait il ya le plan de relance
le sénat aussi d'autres textes et hasard
qu'on est vraiment une
un exemple concret cette semaine donc
nous avons marié toute la journée
examiné un certain nombre d'orientations
gouvernementale avec des amendements de
députés ont facilité l'installation de
nouvelles industries alors évidemment
certains y voyaient une atteinte au
droit de l'environnement etc
si jamais vous avez lu des informations
de cette nature là non c'est faux il ya
aucun moment le le code de
l'environnement a été défait ou altérés
par asap
simplement il était question d'accélérer
permettre une simplification des
procédures
voilà avec toujours un certain nombre de
garanties dans cette logique de d'avoir
un plan de relance et à côté met en
place tout toutes les possibilités pour
aller très vite
peut-être pour nous l'occasion de
reparler d'hazard et auquel cas je crois
qu'elles sont les meilleures grandes
orientations qui ont été prises pour
faciliter quotidien la vie d'ex penser
merci beaucoup
on s'est lancé sur les sujets de
l'assemblée nationale je vois jean marie
vanlerenberghe on va évidemment parler
du sénat dans quelques dans quelques
instants
mais je voudrais rester sur le plan de
relance il ya une question qu'on entend
beaucoup qui remonte c'est la question
du financement
on finance ce plan de relance et j'ai
parlé de la mobilisation de l'épargné
des français également qui est un sujet
est ce que patrick que tu ne veut nous
dire un mot comment comment on finance
aujourd'hui ce plan de relance
durablement patrick sinon
lequel souhaite répond peut-être jean
noël qui peut poursuivre je patrie
contentant pas si tu tentes de parler
alors assez bon voilà c'est bon donc
donc tu a soulevé la question du
financement parce que la grande
inquiétude c'est de se dire le 100
milliards comment on le finance
alors bon jean noël il est bien plus
intelligente mois pour expliquer comment
on en prend aujourd'hui la direction du
trésor à des taux négatifs
donc ça doit quand même nous rassurer
mais ce qu'il faut savoir sur tout c'est
que on a à peu près 40% presque 40% du
plan de relance qui est financé par
l'union européenne
donc on pourrait se dire quelque part
d'abord quand même observer que c'est la
première fois qu'il va y avoir une
initiative budgétaire de cette ampleur
au niveau de l'union européenne
ça c'est une grande victoire d'emmanuel
macro et d'angela merkel
mais on pourrait se dire quelque part on
est en train de de diffuser ou de
transférer à l'europe
la charge fiscale qui sera celle du plan
de relance et à tel n'est pas le cas
l'objectif est que l'europe où
évidemment des ressources propres pour
financer sa partie du plan de relance
cette ressource propre zéro sur ce
procès la taxe carbone aux frontières
et c'est la taxe sur les géants du
numérique vous savez à quel point nous
on s'est battu l assemblée nationale
pour qu' il ya une fiscalité qui soit
beaucoup plus d'activités nouvelles et
la plus part du temps et chaptal impôts
même quand elle fabrique de l'argent ce
soit dans notre pays ou à l'intérieur
des frontières de l'union européenne
ensuite j'ai une deuxième partie qui est
de l'emprunt français à partir de peu
près une trentaine de milliards
et ça ce sont effectivement chez à celle
là c'est de la dette supplémentaire
mais comme on l'a dit très régulièrement
dans toutes les campagnes qu'on a fait
avec françois bayrou
notre préoccupation pour la dette
c'était précisément de se mettre en
condition de que le pays puisse lorsque
il était touché par une crise grave et
profonde qu'il soit capable de lever
cette dette et compte tenu de la
notation financière compte tenu de la
qualité du pays de la qualité de
signature et puis je crois que la
qualité des efforts de réformes qu'on a
fait depuis trois ans on est capable de
financer cette dette ça pèse sur les
arbres défense
et enfin les derniers 30 milliards en
fait ce sont ce sont 30 milliards qu'on
aurait pu tout simplement perdre si nous
ne relançons pas parce que il est bien
évident que si demain l'économie
française rester durablement avec des
reculs autour de - 8 - 9 % de croissance
la perte en termes de ressources
fiscales de tva ou de rentrées dures
sache assez naturellement serait très
largement supérieure je me permets
d'insister là dessus parce que en fait
il faut qu'on ait en tête que il ya une
grande inquiétude des français qu'ils il
me faudra bien que quelqu'un paye un
jour ça viendra et forcément ce sera nos
impôts
ça ne sera pas le cas nous avons pris
l'engagement solennel qu'il n'y ait pas
d'augmentation d'impôts et c'est très
important parce que comme tu l'a bien
souligné tout à l'heure il ya deux plans
de relance il ya le plan de relance de
100 milliards que nous allons voter à
partir de la semaine prochaine et il ya
un deuxième plan de relance qui peut
exister c'est 100 milliards d' épargne
accumulée par les français de plus
pendant le creux vide et donc si demain
ils reprennent confiance
ils sont capables de faire en sorte que
en réalité ce soit deux fois 100
milliards qui reviennent dans l'économie
française
on sauver les emplois en particulier de
nos alors j'ai une question qui vient
des internautes à laquelle j'imagine il
est très difficile de répondre
en combien de temps la crise économique
doit-elle se résorber et comment
est-elle comment allons-nous rembourser
l'emprunt tu as tué en partie répondu
mais la question du temps combien de
temps va durer la crise économique
j'imagine qu'il est bien difficile d'y
répondre peut-être qu'il ya des pistes
des modèles patrick alors l'objectif est
que nous puissions retrouver au premier
trimestre 2001 de la situation dans
laquelle nous étions avant la crise
c'est l'objectif qu'on a donné
d'ailleurs en transparence parce que ça
doit faut dire les choses aux français
si on veut qu'ils reprennent confiance
la paire bête soulignait qu avant la
crise nous étions dans une situation que
le pays n'avait pas connue depuis 17 ou
18 ans
avec une baisse du chômage à un niveau
de chômage qui n'avait jamais atteint un
niveau aussi bas et avec un niveau de
croissance qui était supérieur à la
plupart des pays comparables est
supérieur à celui de l'allemagne permet
de souligner donc c'était un objectif
très ambitieux évidemment d'arriver à
cette situation
début 2000 22 je crois que il s'agit pas
que du gouvernement ou des
parlementaires si nous sommes bons dans
ce plan de relance
nous pouvons y arriver c'est à dire que
dès l'an prochain il faut que sur les
100 milliards de plans de relance on
était incapable de capacités décaissés
au moins 30 milliards et savez tout le
boulot des parlementaires et des élus
locaux en particulier de la famille
politique d'aller chercher tous les
projets d'investissements qu'on peut
faire dans l'industrie française dans la
relocalisation industrielle dans les
investissements publics mais chez moi
cet après midi je discutais sur le
l'implantation d'une boucle d'eau de
création de d'énergie d'au total de 2
d'énergie totalement d'écart boeing
boucle d'eau sur le lac du bourget comme
les spis le font d'ailleurs sur le lac
léman depuis dix ans d'un coût de 25
millions d'euros
je vais proposer ce projet là où pour
comprendre relance donc c'est 30
milliards l'année prochaine
c'est lors de l'année 2022
l'engagement des 70 milliards restant au
fond
les mesures que nous avons prises
jusqu'à présent ont déjà commencé à
porter leurs fruits et c'est ce qui nous
donne un peu d'optimisme parce que les
projections de la banque de france nous
disait qu'on serait à -11 à la fin de
cette année ils sont en train de revoir
leurs prévisions de déficits de
croissance de baisse de la croissance
quand il était à moins 8 points 7
alors on va pas se bagarrer sur les
chiffres mais si à la fin de l'année où
elle est ramenée à 11 on est plutôt à -8
et mélanie prochaine en est capable
c'est la prévision et c'est l'ambition
que nous portons de faire un plus aux
bus on se dit ça + 11 % pour la france
alors à ce moment là on sera au rendez
vous du premier trimestre 2009 22 et
puis toute façon on a intérêt à y mourir
parce que là pour le coup en toute
transparence les français iront ensuite
aux urnes
et et nous dirons stop ou encore alors
sur sur cette question du plan de
relance toujours qu est un sujet majeur
on entend souvent la question de
l'emploi et je voudrais interrogé michel
devaux couleur et sans doute
bin hamman sur la question de quel
emploi parce qu'évidemment rebâtir
reconstruire mais pas comme avant tout
le monde le dit comment ont choisi quel
type de filière on va aller privilégiez
chercher reconstruire encre quels types
de filières seront sans doute moins
soutenue si elle ne se transforme pas à
ces questions sont j'imagine très
difficile est ce que michel michel de
vaucouleurs député des yvelines réagir
sur ce sujet de l'emploi avec sylvain
peut-être ensuite il faut allumer
ok question quel paquet pas simple avec
elle mais pas celle d'apporter une
réponse eu une réponse très simple
quel métier pour demain on a évoqué la
transition écologique
c est vraiment un better effectivement
sur lesquels on devra se retrouver et
fort mais on a notamment eu notamment
celles et métiers d'art le bois sur la
reconstruction de notre dame en
développent des blocs de l'apprentissage
spécialisé sur les métiers d'art c'est
c'est une opportunité à la faveur d'un
drame et notamment sur le département
des yvelines en ile-de-france on aura ce
cfa cfa dédié aux métiers d'art à
versailles ce qu'est vraiment ce que
l'on chouette
et puis bien sûr il ya tous les métiers
du service du service à la personne du
service de proximité métier un métier
mal mal rémunérés main construit en
difficulté aussi de formation donc il
faut mieux former des gens pour mieux
les payer et de refaire des conditions
de travail plus satisfaisante aussi on a
bien sûr tout toutes les conséquences
qu'on doit tirer du ségur de la santé
voulez encore
il s'agit de former encore davantage de
personnel j'étais hier à j'étais hier à
versailles ont rencontré des
sages-femmes et donc les seychelles vous
disait par exemple on a voulu les matins
on aidé des petites structures ce qui
est une bonne chose en matière de
sécurité
par contre il y avait des règles en
termes de personnel qui était valable
jusqu'à 2000 accouchements par an avec
des quotas de personnel jusqu'à 2000
2001 accouchements par an et il n'y a
pas eu aujourd'hui la des unités qui
font presque le double et il n'y a pas
eu de revalorisation de ces quotas ce
qui fait que on peut selon le directeur
de l'établissement
on peut fonctionner aujourd'hui sur des
établissements de 4l minescence avec des
contingents comparons pas évolué donc
moi je chatte est vraiment l'attention
en termes de en termes de métiers fab et
aimant tout sur tous ses métiers du
sanitaire et du social sur lesquels on
doit vraiment investir puissamment et
des métiers des transitions aussi
écologique bien sûr sur lesquels il faut
pas comprends pas qu'on rate le coche
voilà pour ce que je vois de mon côté
mais je passe volontiers la parole à
silvan qui lui a peut-être un autre
regard sur la question si le vin le
waserman qui est donc député du
haut-rhin baobab merci merci beaucoup
bonjour à toutes et à tous le message
que j'aimerais porter ces deux choses
d'abord tu sais que avec les un jeu
qu'on a sur l'emploi aujourd'hui c'est
le moment d'être audacieux et du fer et
faisait référence prônons un ouvrage que
j'ai paru il ya j'ai pu il ya quinze
jours qu'ils savaient le monde après
commence demain matin et en matière
d'emploi il ya des propositions assez
clair et développement économique jean
donne deux exemples pour pas être trop
long le premier c'est que je pense qu'il
faut expérimenter la décentralisation de
pôle emploi de la fonction
opérationnelle de pôle emploi qui mêle
offre en face de la demande et je pense
que les régions qui sont plus près des
territoires un dialogue quotidien avec
les entreprises sont plus à même que
pôle emploi aujourd'hui de gérer
l'adéquation de l'offre et de la demande
dans une situation qui est tendu et qui
nécessitent d'être audacieux et de
prendre des initiatives le deuxième
exemple
c'est un exemple que que j'ai porté dans
un groupe de travail ou dans le maire
qui est la création de fonds souverains
régionaux pour que la collectivité
régionale puissent investir en fonds
propres ou quasi fonds propres côté les
entreprises sur des projets de
développement des projets comme
ce qui permet notamment d'avoir une
action volontariste dans les domaines du
développement durable donc des exemples
il y en a beaucoup il ya beaucoup
d'idées moi je crois que il faut se
laisser la chance d'expérimenter d'avoir
un peu d'audace et puis le deuxième une
deuxième point que j'aimerais faire
c'est que chacun peut agir c'est dans ma
circonscription est on est on est
plusieurs à lancer cette initiative au
sein du modem on va en faire une petite
signature politique l'ancienne
initiative qui s'appelle les jeunes vers
l'emploi
je les ai testés pendant un an il ya un
an avec un coaching de personnes qui
travaillent en entreprise et qui
accompagne des jeunes des quartiers vers
l'emploi ça marche ça marche très bien
donc on a décidé de faire x 10 avec la
maison de l'emploi de strasbourg et on
lance des grands pointe de coaching et
c'est très bien parce que les gens qui
travaillent en entreprise qui ont de la
chance d'avoir un emploi
passés les premiers à se relever les
manches pour accompagner les jeunes vers
l'emploi
le message c'est tout le monde peut agir
concrètement et moi mon rêve c'est que
d'ici 2022
en tout cas c'est que les 300 jeunes
qu'on accompagne là et qu'on va
accompagner dans l'est dans les deux ans
à venir mais on puisse avoir leur
témoignage et couvrir ma permanence de
tous leurs témoignages pour montrer que
concrètement on peut aussi agir voilà je
le fais court mais c'est des sujets
évidemment clé parce que leur aide je
sais c'est d'abord vous tous merci
sylvain peut-être erwan qui voulait
prendre la parole sur l'emprunt sur la
question du rôle du rôle de l'europe
et puis reprendra basculer sur un
deuxième sujet plutôt plutôt écologique
nos sénateurs peuvent également
s'exprimer sur tous ces sujets là bien
évidemment même si dira un mot ensuite
plus particulièrement du renouvellement
au sénat erwan redon
oui basile et bonjour à tous c'était
plutôt une réaction tout à l'heure sur
le vif c'était par rapport à ce que
disait très justement patrick moi je
vois aussi quelque chose dans bon déjà
c'est une victoire du président macron
acquis la villa qui a été arraché ce
morceau de cet emprunt est de cet
engagement de toute l'europe et moi j'y
vois quand même aussi un symbole quelque
chose qui est extrêmement important pour
notre famille politique c'est un moment
où on est en train de construire un
commun européen parce qu'à partir du
moment où on emprunte de façon commune
il va falloir d'une façon ou d'une autre
remboursez de façon commune et je trouve
que c'est un beau signe c'est un beau
signe pour notre famille politique
on est en train de s'engager on est en
train de conforter l'europe qui juste
avant cette période là était en pleine
hésitation pour dans un certain nombre
de pays
et là je crois qu'on a vu quand même que
ensemble on est plus fort tout à leur
ensemble et unis on est les plus forts
et c'était juste cette petite remarque
que je voulais faire qui me semblent eux
qui me semble important et se dire que
on a été capable d'emprunter ensemble ça
veut dire qu'on va être capables de
mener des politiques ensemble
et justement pour faire la transition
sur la question de l'écologie va falloir
qu'on travaille avec les européens parce
que seul on n'y arrivera pas je vais
avant de parler d'écologie je vais donc
la parole hameau de petit qui souhaitait
revenir sur la question de l'emploi
merci beaucoup fabien bonjour à toutes
et à tous
oui je voulais juste eu rajouter deux
mots par rapport à l'emploi pour faire
un petit peu suite à ce que disait mon
collègue sylvain que je salue aussi en
particulier tu parlais tout à l'heure
sylvain du pôle emploi moi je voudrais
dire que sur le bal de marne en fait le
pôle emploi à cieux et je pense que
c'est un petit peu le cas ailleurs aussi
énormément se renouveler depuis une
dizaine d'années ils font un travail
exceptionnel de terrain avec les
entreprises avec les chercheurs d'emploi
et donc ils ont su apporter beaucoup de
nouvelles offres beaucoup de nouvelles
méthodes de travail avec des mises en
situation par exemple je pense que c'est
un acteur sur lequel on peut quand même
compter aujourd'hui à condition qu'ils
veulent véritablement s'investir et
travailler la main dans la main avec
tous les acteurs
ce que je crois est déjà un peu le cas
en tout cas c'est comme ça dans le val
de marne
et puis tout à l'heure aussi michel
rappelait va parler plus
particulièrement des emplois d'avenir
il faut absolument pas non plus oublier
les métiers qui existent depuis fort
longtemps et qui sont en difficulté
aujourd'hui et je pense en particulier
tous aimé astier qui sont rattachés à la
culture
les intermittents du spectacle avec qui
j'ai discuté un petit peu cet après-midi
en circonscription
les gens les acteurs du monde de la nuit
tous ceux qui ont l'impression
aujourd'hui d'être oubliée et qui
pourtant contribué énormément à ce que
notre pays est ce que les français et
les françaises se sent bien au quotidien
quand on a une longue journée de travail
et bien c'est agréable d'aller prendre
un bar dans un verre dans un bar avec
des amis jusqu'à tard peut-être le week
end allait pouvoir danser un petit peu
pour évacuer les mauvaises idées ou les
périodes difficiles de la journée donc
il faut absolument pas non plus que nous
oublions dans le plan de relance
toutes ces personnes qui font un travail
formidable à l'année pour nous divertir
et qui peut-être aujourd'hui se sentent
encore oublié donc sur eux
le plan culturel va falloir vraiment que
notre ministre roselyne bachelot envoie
des signaux à très très important voilà
ma petite intervention je te remercie
fabien merci modes de jeux partage
évidemment mille fois ton avis sur les
souffrances du monde culturel
actuellement avant de passer la parole à
un jean marie pour peut-être un point de
vue du sénat sur l'emploi qui connaît
ces questions parker sur l'emploi de
demain et pour compléter ce qui a été
dit je voudrais saluer lundi le brocart
député du rhône et michel crouzet député
de l'yonne qui nous ont rejoints
récemment donc je leur fais un amical
salut elles prennent la parole
naturellement des cadets qu'elle le
souhaite comme vous toutes et tous jean
marie est ce que tu veux compléter ce
qui a été dit sur cette question des
emplois et la transformation de l'emploi
notamment grâce au plan de relance
je pense que ce qui a été dit est
injuste je pense que pôle emploi bien
évolué et qu'elle est aujourd'hui
c'est une agence qui est en capacité de
répondre aux enjeux vaut mais je crois
qu'elle a une faiblesse qui est bien
connu de la baraque toutes les
collectivités locales
c'est sur l'insertion est aussi bien
l'insertion des jeunes que l'insertion
des seniors ou des personnes
effectivement en chômage de longue durée
donc il ya nécessité de la barre
que des collectivités à travers la
mission locale à travers les plis
d'intervenir pour agir efficacement avec
les élus locaux avec des entreprises
locales pour favoriser cette accession
j'entendais tout à l'heure se disait
sylvain laserman sur le coup le coaching
on la paie ça avant le parrainage sano
plus français mais c'est la même idée
je pense qu'il est indispensable de
bagneux des jeunes et les seniors on les
oublie souvent vers l'endroit les
accompagner ça veut dire effectivement
leur donner la possibilité de s'essayer
d'un emploi pas seulement de faire je
dirais l'accompagnement à travers tilman
quelques jeux et quelques séances autour
d'une table non mais c'est de les mettre
directement en situation en entreprise
chez moi on a réussi comme ça nobilise
et le 250 300 entreprises qui sont prêts
à favoriser l'immersion de ces jeunes je
crois que c'est une démarche qui est
essentiel qui est complémentaire de ce
que faisons avec la garantie jeunes la
guerre anti jeunes qui va se développer
complémentaire aussi de l'action que le
gouvernement à favoriser pour
l'alternance évidemment sauver je dirais
même durant cette période un peu
difficile la formation par l'alternance
donc pour moi voilà ce que j'ajouterai à
tout ce qui est dit évidemment acquis et
focus sur l'évolution des métiers et je
pense que rien à adopter si ce n'est à
dire qu'il ya des métiers et notamment
des métiers de l'artisanat des métiers
manuels qui est aujourd'hui commence à
redevenir effectivement à très attractif
pour les jeunes
encore faut-il effectivement que nous
puissions les présenter et que les
parents comprennent que le sait mal
d'échéances que de ne pas avoir à col
blanc
encore que les lieux de travail les
métiers manuels avec un col blanc au
jaune
merci beaucoup jean marie surtout tu
restes avec nous on aura des élections
sénatoriales dans une semaine et je
voudrais tu puisse nous faire un petit
panorama de cette élection un petit peu
plus tard dans la conversation
on va passer maintenant au chapitre de
l'écologie ou sur ce sujet majeur
un sentiment dominant tout cas beaucoup
de beaucoup de nos concitoyens se pose
des questions sur la caisse sur le sujet
précisément de comment prioriser les
principes écologiques au mans prioriser
les mesures écologiques
comment résoudre un certain nombre de
contradictions car on voit bien qu'un
certain nombre d'actions rendu
nécessaire ont des impacts écologiques
et qu'elle crée des débats je pense bien
évidemment au sujet des néonicotinoïdes
qui sont peut-être assez emblématique de
nos contradictions de nos difficultés de
cette transformation qui nous faut qu'il
me faut opérer et serait intéressant que
vous me disiez comment au fond notre
groupe
nos parlementaires porte une parole un
peu singulière sur cette question
l'objectif est partagé le chemin pour y
parvenir évidemment aucun parti
politique dans la halle monopole et
certainement pas le parti europe
ecologie les verts
donc comment est-ce qu'on contribue à ce
débat comment est-ce qu'on résout en
tout cas ont contribué à la résolution
de ces contradictions aujourd'hui que
les français perçoit bien on veut
changer de comportement on veut
transformer la société et le modèle
néanmoins ça coince à de nombreuses
reprises sur ce sujet plus généralement
de l'écologie je vais passer la parole à
un florange florence lasserre député des
pyrénées-atlantiques je vois pas bruno
myle yen qui devait être avec nous
peut-être sur le sujet des
néonicotinoïdes mais si l'un d'entre
vous verrez âgées et les malades
alors on excuse si l'un d'entre vous
font réagir précisément sur ce sujet je
crois que l'opinion publique mais
florence de manière plus générale sur 7
merci bonjour tout le monde je
m'entendais très bien c'est bon pour
faire un très rapide retour sur sur ce
plan de relance et la part et à part de
la transition écologique là dedans sur
ces 5 milliards dont on parle depuis
tout à l'heure au lieu depuis plusieurs
jours
il y en a trente qui seront consacrés la
transition écologique donc c'est quand
même en fait c'est un chapitre énorme de
ce plan de relance et il faut vraiment
le rappeler avec en plus de ceux de ce
budget et de ce montant qui sera alloué
la volonté de tous de faire de ce plan
de de faire passer ce plan de relance
par la transition écologique et par un
bon écologie sur ces 35 milliards
yala 11 qui seront consacrés aux
transports on a neuf qui seront pour
l'industrie et l'énergie set et demi
pour les bâtiments et les logements la
rénovation des logements et 2 pour le
pour l'agriculture dans les transports
il y en a 4 4 et demi qui seront
affectés au désenclavement des
territoires 700 millions d'euros pour
l'ile-de-france pour les transports en
ile-de-france deux simples pour les
transports en commun régionaux et 175
pour le fluvial le canton de va on veut
que c'est que les sept milliards d'euros
qui sont destinés au bâtiment la
rénovation des bâtiments et des
logements
et pour objectif l'économie d'énergie et
la réduction des gaz à effet de serre
donc c'est un bon cherche depuis des
années comment être efficace là dessus
on sait que en matière de de transition
énergétique il ya deux choses il faut
sortir du tout nucléaire mais pas pour
repasser vers du tout hydrogène ou autre
chose et que il faut
d'un autre côté considérablement baissé
nos consommations
donc c'est un des objectifs de ceux de
ce plan de relance
il y a une autre enveloppe est
extrêmement importante et qui est très
cher à jimmy je pense qu'il est à
d'autres natures et je pense qu'ils
pourraient en parler c'est les 300
millions qui sont alloués qui sont
dédiés à
à la lutte contre l'artificialisation
des sols dans ses quelque chose qui est
important pour le modèle ex me tient à
coeur
9 milliards pour dans la transition
énergétique qui vont faire la part belle
à l'hydrogène qui est quelque chose
qu'on peut mettre en avant dans le pays
et enfin sur l'agriculture il ya 400
millions pour la transition
agroécologiques 250 pour la
modernisation de la filière animale la
sécurité sanitaire et un sujet comme les
néonicotinoïdes qui revient beaucoup en
ce moment qu'ils lui liaient à la tran
images et on peut citer aussi 250
millions qui seront alloués à la
biodiversité dans les territoires donc
cette enveloppe le jeu vous et je vous
ai dit rapidement pour qu'on vous ayez
une idée en tête de tous qui de tout ce
qui est tout ce qui est préparé
actuellement cette enveloppe des 30
milliards comme c'est comme ces 100
milliards le plus le plus gros danger
effectivement falloir les rend possible
le plus gros danger ce serait pour les
consomme pas tout alors jean noël parler
de la territorialisation de ce plan de
relance
on va on va rentrer dans l'étude du
texte aussi donc c'est un exercice qui
va être difficile mais il faut
absolument qu'on réussisse
et puis de toute façon on était habitué
parce que ça fait trois ans qu'on a des
équations assez difficile un réseau donc
dans quel onze y voilà merci beaucoup
florence est important de rappeler ces
chiffres ils paraissent parfois un petit
peu loin et hors sol est trop grand mais
c'est extrêmement concret et une fille
née en action j'aurais passé la parole à
un jimmy n'est pas une député du
morbihan qui s'est beaucoup impliqué
notamment sur la question de la lutte
contre les plastiques et puis peut-être
erwan aussi après qui s'implique sur ces
sujets tout le monde le sait notamment
avec le groupe accélérons à l'assemblée
nationale trans partisan donc sur cette
question précisément à jimmy et pu opter
pour la question des néonicotinoïdes
peut-être que c'est important de tourner
ils comprennent bien ce qu'il ya
derrière cette histoire parce que je
crois qu'elle est assez révélatrice
d'une série de contradictions
oui bonsoir à tous ces concerts fabien
et puis en préambule je voulais encore
publicité est notre président mignola
quand même d'avoir ouvert le groupe ad
nouvelle intelligence et des nouveaux
esprits qui nous rejoignent chesnais
modem et apparentés et rappeler que c
est quand même assez
c'est fantastique
que trois ans après les élections la
majorité s'agrandissent c'est ça c'est
quand même une bonne nouvelle et
remettons toujours des bonnes nouvelles
au dessus de la pile alors sur cette
transition écologique on a eu de très
bons échanges avec pascal canfin député
européen marie pierre blais de reine
catherine chabaud qui était nous
laurence qui était également avec nous à
biscarrosse ya quelques jours et
qu'enfin nous rappeler quand même
quelques chiffres 1 c'est que la fatwa
de la fantastique bagarre du prium la
république pour que l'europe soit le
premier continent qui arrive à réduire
ses gaz à effet de serre je pense que
tous nos toulon tous nos projets tous
nos projets de territoire et doivent
être pensées un petit peu dans ce seul
dans ce tout le projet industriel de
territoire ne doit penser que dans ce
seul but qui est finalement d'arriver à
baisser nos gaz à effet de serre alors
moi sur la circonscription
et puis j'ai le bonheur d'avoir une une
lcp qui allait suivre deux jours jeudi
et vendredi sur j'ai tout de suite
présenté trois projets 2 que j'avais
déjà proposé au préfet et aux élus
depuis longtemps qu'ils sont une
laiterie à belle-ile et puis un
cheminement de train qui amène les gens
de la gare d'auray à belle isle parce
que finalement petit biberon bélisle a
même presque autant de monde que le
mont-saint-michel donc mériterait un
transport entre pour à des jeux sur les
îles et puis un troisième qui est un
transport de passagers entre l'arrêt de
gauche et la rive droite de lorient pour
ceux qui la connaissent et qui elle
transporte raid 1 millions de passagers
alors là il faut que j'arrive à ramener
tout le monde et je suis content de
porter un peu cette idée là parce que je
le sentiment que que que déjà le préfet
du morbihan qui a été carrément en avant
garde un petit peu sur toute cette crise
du coc vite parce que nous avons et des
clusters un peu plus tôt que tout le
monde lui pour l'instant son attention
et il m'a dit c'est de refaire le réseau
d'eau qui sont partout en france
assez défaillant et puis le porter aussi
beaucoup de mobilité de pistes cyclables
je vais essayer de convaincre à nous
suivre deux sur ces projets là moi je
sur le nez on ne connaît qu'une et
continue on va avoir un débat important
je crois que il fallait faire quelque
chose pour celle de suivirent des trains
je crois c 46 mille emplois je pense que
bruno duvergé ou ring ou marguerite
audebert sont vraiment en paix de la
betterave et nous et nous le dirons 46
mille emplois moi je regrette un petit
peu et ça va ça va être top chine
les dialogues de la semaine prochaine
parce que nous on va passer pour des
gens qui n'ont pas réussi à mettre en
avant un petit peu un un projet de loi
qui était porté il ya cinq ans déjà et
sur cette transition c'est alors ya le
prennent des maîtresses mais vous savez
que le maïs la noisette le colza
tous souffrent aussi un petit peu de la
fin de ces nonnes et cottineau id
moi je vais essayer que j'ai essayé de
porter je voudrais qu'on portent tous un
amendement qui s'il faut encore avec des
hivers doux
une fois peut-être accompagné encore des
agriculteurs dans dans la douceur et
dans la haie dans la transition mais il
faudra que à la prochaine demande de
néonicotinoïdes qui nous feront il
faudra déjà qu'ils aient fait un petit
peu d'épreuves et qu'ils aient déjà
commencé à remettre des ailes à remettre
début où les abeilles de butiner plus
facilement que sur les betteraves
je voudrais vraiment que que les choses
soient faites un petit peu en en échange
de mai d'avancé que nous aurons prouver
un petit peu nos agriculteurs ja soir
j'étais une réunion assez intéressante
et assez est assez volontaire vous savez
qu'on a un vrai problème d'algues vertes
en bretagne
on a essayé et c'est un fléau voir ces
algues vertes
on m'avait réussi la région bretagne a
réussi à baisser de 30%
produits la production de ces nitrates
en organisant mieux un petit peu nos
porcherie donc houdayer et puis à côté
de saab a parfois été assez souvent on
organise aussi on permet aussi d
agrandissement de porcherie de
poulaillers je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on puisse je pense qu'on a un mandat
peut-être deux mandats de déjà récupéré
un petit peu toutes nos friche qui est
déployée qui s'agrandissent pourquoi cas
mais qu'on les a grandi il ya des
poulaillers et sur le terrain des
existants voilà c'est un petit peu ces
choses là que je portais parce que
sincèrement et pour terminer nous sommes
une majorité qui a fait beaucoup de
choses pour la transition écologique
rappelez-vous notre dame des landes
rappelez-vous europa city rappelez-vous
en 2040 on aura plus de voitures à
l'essence
enfin deux voitures louées aura plus de
voitures à essence en 2040
on ne pourra plus on ne pourra plus fort
et en mer et à terre
et puis cette grande loi qu'on a monté
sur le l'économie circulaire il faut
vraiment qu'on soit capable de la vendre
et déjà saint samedi ce sont des grandes
grandes avancées sur le plan
environnemental
merci beaucoup avant de passer la parole
à erwan j'en profite pour saluer luc
gennart députés leur atlantique qui a
pris la suite de ça devenu secrétaire
d'état donc je lui fais également un
amical coucou et je salue sa présence
erwan et puis ensuite sophie mette nous
dira un petit mot également sur la
question de la forêt erwan balanant
député du finistère
ouais jimmy jimmy est formidable quand
il parle d'écologie
parce que c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
engagé d'ailleurs comme à peu près tous
les députés de ce groupe c'est une de
nos particularités c'est que c'est qu'on
pense vraiment que c'est un sujet alors
moi moi tu l'a rappelé jeu j'ai la
chance d'animer un c'est pas du tout la
présidence ni quoi que ce soit c'est
juste l'animation entre eux en deux mots
c'est juste un peu les emmerdes entre
guillemets d'un groupe de 178 2
ut trans partisan où on travaille autour
de l'écologie est bon sur la question
des néo néo c'est très dur à dire j'y
arrive jamais donc sur la question des
pesticides et sur ces pesticides en
particulier c'est extrêmement révélateur
des enjeux que nous avons devant sur la
question de la transition c'est que on a
la conviction on le sait que c'est de la
mauvaise solution et c'est les solutions
dont il faut sortir ces pesticides sont
un impact extrêmement néfastes sur
l'environnement je crois qu'aujourd'hui
personne ne dira le contraire sauf quand
à côté de ça on a une filière on a une
filière qui doit s'organiser pour cette
transition et moi ce que je regrette
essai c'est un petit peu la même chose
que que jim lee c'est que ça fait ça
fait presque dix ans maintenant plus de
10 ans et 2009 l'interdiction de ces
pesticides au niveau de l'européen il ya
eu des dérogations les dérogations
existent parce qu'il n'ya pas de
solution pour l'instant
enfin y'a pas de solution qui à grande
échelle et qui fonctionne mais on sait
qu'il ya des solutions on sait qu'il
faut travailler différemment c'est qu'il
faut faire de la rotation sur les sur
les champs de betteraves
on sait qu'il faut planter des haies
aujourd'hui nous avons déterré une
région betteravière où il ya plus du
tout des essais ce qui permet pas la
biodiversité d'attaquer les pucerons qui
sont responsables de cette fameuse
jaunisse il ya un très bon article dans
sciences et avenir qui explique très
bien le processus est donc l'enjeu c'est
de la transition et l'enjeu c'est moi si
le groupe on dit souvent et c'est
souvent ce que dit bruno myle yen qui
visiblement malade j'espère que c'est
pas trop grave il n'y a pas de
transition sans solution et c'est
hellénique néonicotinoïdes pardon c'est
long c'est notre problématique c'est que
sur eux
on n'a pas de solution sur le très court
terme et donc c'est pour ça qu'on va ré
accompagner les ailes et les
cultivateurs et les agriculteurs et moi
ça me fend le coeur de voir les
accompagnent fin de devoir refaire cette
dérogation mais on n'a pas d'autre
solution pour en moins cette période
mais l'enjeu c'est que dès maintenant et
qu'il faut qu'ils s'engagent et c'est
peut-être que dans le texte et c'est
peut-être ce qu'on aura nous comme
comme particularité sur ce texte avec
des amendements jimmy on verra qu aussi
à des amendements du groupe plus aux
autres il faut qu'il y ait des
engagements forts qu'ils soient
quasiment de l'ordre du contrat j'ai
envie de dire pour que cette filière
s'organise différemment et qu'elle s'en
sorte parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison
que les autres filières ont réussi à
s'en sortir il n'y a pas de raison que
des filières comme le maïs c'est parfois
difficile mais ils ont réussi à se
passer de ce type de d'un sigle de
pesticides et tout l'enjeu il est là si
on ne fait pas effectivement non on va
passer pour des gens régressive sur
cette question-là auprès de l'opinion
publique alors que judy milad il a
parfaitement montré les trois ans du
début du quinquennat de président du
président macro ont été des idées et on
était un un moment de vraie avancée sur
la question l'écologie donc il faut
continuer et accélérer encore merci
beaucoup et roanne je vais passer la
parole à à sophie mette mode petit et et
philippe beaux lots ensuite on devra
encore abordé la question du régalien on
dira un mot de la loi à venir également
de l'international et des élections
sénatoriales donc je vais prendre que
trois interventions encore sur ce sujet
écologique je passe la parole à sophie
mette député de labelle gironde dont sa
fabia lanceur à toutes et à tous moi je
voulais rajouter un petit mot rapport à
ce qu'a dit florence lasserre tout à
l'heure j'ai je participe au groupe
d'étude bois et forêts et jeudi on avait
avec anthony scellier donc qui est
député marcheurs en off on a participé à
aux 24 heures pour le climat donc
j'avais une table ronde en
circonscriptions sur la forêt est ce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui bien dire c'est
que les les forestiers toute la filière
bois forêt est très contente de du plan
de relance et des moyens qui sont donnés
à la forêt ça fait des décennies que il
n'y avait pas eu autant d'argent qu'ils
allaient
et a abondé cette filière je crois que
si je ne trompe pas c'est 250 millions
d'euros
ça va alors leur permettre de travailler
sur tout ce qui concerne les plans les
graines aussi le reboisement en
particulier sur la partie grand est de
la france mais pas uniquement et je
crois que c'est c'était important à
souligner je crois que les forestiers
sont vraiment très heureux de cette
annonce dans le cadre du plan de relance
alors quatre lots a remis un rapport
jeudi justement sur sur la forêt sur
l'état de la forêt française
je ne vais pas étudier encore je pense
qu'à certains points qui ceux qui sont
très en faveur de la forêt il y aura
certainement des petits points qui
seront plus délicats comme le sujet des
coupes rases là aussi il y aura des
discussions
comme beaucoup de sujets
environnementaux écologique on va dire
mais voilà je voulais féliciter et
remercier tout est à la fois le
gouvernement et la filière qui va
s'engager aussi bien pour pour pour
travailler ils sont ils sont prêts à
vraiment à travailler pour affiner ce
plan de relance aussi sur la recherche
il travaille énormément sur la recherche
il faut le savoir pour avec les
problèmes de réchauffement climatique
il ya énormément de recherches qui sont
faits pour avoir les meilleurs plans
qu'ils puissent s'adapter à toute cette
modification malheureusement tous ces
modifications que nous avons jeu je vais
laisser la parole parce que je crois que
il ya beaucoup de monde après - merci
merci mon petit peut-être avec un
éclairage sur les outre-mers notre votre
collègue justine bénin notre collègue
député de la guadeloupe avait posé une
question également à l'assemblée
nationale sur cette question
de ne pas oublier les autres maires à la
fois dans le temps de relance mais aussi
sur cette question écologique mode
oui exactement je voudrais avoir un mot
particulier sur les autres maps à ce que
la france elle est très belle mais la
france ça n'est pas que la métropole et
ne faut jamais jamais oublier nono
ultramarins qui nous apporte beaucoup de
richesses je voudrais en fait expliqué
qu'il va falloir qu'on soit très très
vigilants sur la question de l'écologie
aussi donc en outre-mer parce qu'il ya
des sujets relativement important et qui
perdure qui existe depuis longtemps et
sur lesquels on a eu la volonté
probablement d'avancé mais pour lesquels
on n'a pas encore trouvé de réponse
et donc c'est un mauvais signal qui est
envoyé à la population ultramarine
parce que notre gouvernement s'il échoue
s'il ne fait rien eh bien je vais le
dire au site river trivialement mais ces
populations-là donneront leurs bulletins
de vote a d'autres qui peuvent être très
dangereux on n'en mesure peut-être pas
encore l'impact ici en métropole mais
c'est le front national qui prend les
devants sur ces territoires là nous
avons les sujets donc relativement
importants comme les sargasses et
lorsque nicolas hulot était encore
ministre et l'avait promis d'avancer des
millions d'euros pour qu'on puisse
traiter et résoudre cette question des
sargasses ça n'est pas le cas je suis
allé en martinique cet été pour une
quinzaine de jours
il ya encore des zones et des plages sur
lesquelles vous avez les sargasses qui
sont véritablement toxiques
non seulement elle vous empêche les
empêche aux marins pêcheurs d'aller de
quitter en fête la terre pour aller
chercher les poissons mais aussi vous
avez de véritables nuisances vis-à-vis
de tout ce qui est métallique parce que
les sargasses avec lui le rôdeur elles
ont une toxicité qui fait que ça abîme
tout ce qui est mécanique ça peut vous
ayez des moteurs de voiture enfin c'est
voilà donc il faut vraiment qu'on
travaille sur ces sujets là dans les
deux ans qu'il nous reste
il faut qu'on envoie des signaux forts
parce que sinon on perdra les antilles
en l'occurrence sur ce problème là
il ya des sujets très très délicat aussi
comme celui dans la montagne d'or et
j'avais applaudi des deux mains lorsque
le président emmanuel macron avait
indiqué qu'il mettait de côté ce projet
je crois qu'il va revenir à l'ordre du
jour or c'est une question qui a dit
vise énormément mais je crois que les
guyanais ne sont pas très très divisé
sur le sujet alors qu on acte les bons
choix aussi je voudrais juste donné un
dernier un dernier exemple quand on
pesticides et erwan on a bien parlé
nous avions sûrs aux antilles ce qu'on
appelle le chlordécone et ça parlera
peut-être un certain d'entre vous qui
êtes un pesticide qui avait été
interdite dans les années 70 80 aux
etats unis du fait de sa dangerosité et
qui malheureusement bien qu'interdit en
france aussi a continué d'être épandu
sur sur des champs les champs de bananes
notamment en martinique et en guadeloupe
on sait aujourd'hui que ce produit est
tellement dangereux qu'il a pollué les
sols aux anticorps pour des siècles
en fait et comme probablement il
entraîne des conséquences sur la santé
des habitants là bas comme des cancers
de la prostate très probablement de la
fertilité qui ont relativement
importante et d'aider des malformations
sur sur les bébés donc vraiment moi
j'appelle de mes voeux que nous
travaillons véritablement sur ces sujets
là sans oublier les outre-mer est que
des sujets aussi importants
on y trouve des solutions rapidement on
a deux ans pour le faire et si on ne le
fait pas je crains que l'on perde les
outre-mer voilà merci beaucoup
mon petit pour ce témoignage au très
fort philippe bolo en deux minutes par
deux mois philippe pour qu'on puisse
ensuite passé sur la loi sur le
séparatisme merci même moins de deux
minutes
en fait les témoignages d'une école de
mes collègues montrent bien toutes les
difficultés qu'on a à faire avancer les
sujets la transition écologique puisque
ce sont vraiment les sujets holiday ou
très forte divergence vient de se
greffer là-dessus quelque chose qui est
vraie alors pas sympathique qui sont les
thèses du complot qui fait que
finalement les français sont totalement
perdus sur ces sujets là avec souvent le
sentiment d'une écologie punitive
il y'a une solution à tout ça de mon
point de vue je milite pour cela
régulièrement des
quotidiennement c'est une place plus
importante de la science dans la
décision publique
alors évidemment être une difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est que la science
s'inscrit dans le temps long on le voit
avec la copie 19 une décision d'un jour
a été remise en cause de lendemain parce
que les connaissances étaient nouvelles
entre le lendemain et la veille et puis
c'est aussi l'alternative hôpitaux qui
montre que le temps long et nécessaire
et dans l'eau il ya absolument pas
compatible avec ce qu'ils ont envie
aujourd'hui sur sur les réseaux sociaux
il faut une réaction rapide d'une
société immédia lité et faudra aussi se
poser la question de la place de la
science dans l'éducation en tout cas à
l'assemblée et au sénat on travaille sur
ce sujet là au travers d'une dune de
l'opecst ce qui est leur office
parlementaire qui réunit des députés et
des sénateurs
merci beaucoup philippe de la place de
la science dans le débat public se voit
que c'est un sujet pour le
haut-commissariat sujet de réflexion
très intéressant passons maintenant aux
régalien allah nous demandait de thaler
quels sont les projets de lois peuvent
apporter le gros point en tout cas des
projets sur lesquels on va s'y impliquer
le premier ministre jean castex dans son
discours de politique générale a parlé
du séparatisme du risque du repli
communautaire de la radicalisation
il a eu des mots particulièrement fort
sur cette question et je voudrais passer
la parole à isabelle florennes député
des hauts-de-seine
on vous parlait de ce sujet projet de
loi n'est pas encore connu beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses ne sont pas encore
payés mais peut-être que vous pourriez
nous dire une manière assez générale ce
que nous centristes et démocrates à
allons porter ou quelles sont les
préoccupations que nous avons en lien
avec cette fois sur le séparatisme merci
fabien et effectivement j'ai pour
rebondir sur ce que tu viens de dire
j'ai pu interroger réinterroger le
premier ministre et ministre de
l'intérieur lundi et mardi dernier lors
de notre réunion de majorité pour avoir
un peu quelques précisions parce que
c'est un sujet qui nous tient à coeur et
nous avons entendu et nous avons été
heureux d'entendre le président de la
république il y a quelques semaines en
reparler également
au panthéon et réaffirmer ce qui nous
semble important et ceux auxquels notre
parti est attachée et on sait notre
président depuis longtemps c'est à dire
les questions les esses laïcité et de
respect des valeurs de la république
dans notre dans notre pays donc c'était
un engagement de campagne du candidat
emmanuel macron que de que de porter un
projet auront en tout cas de s'attaquer
à ces questions de respect des la
république
on sait très bien depuis un certain
nombre d'années depuis le début des
années 2000 essentiellement depuis une
vingtaine d'années que dans un certain
nombre de deux villes de quartier les
valeurs de la république ne sont plus
respectés et où à l'école ou dans les
clubs sportifs vous ou sur les lieux de
culte même on constate des dérives des
dérives sectaires mais des dérives
importantes
donc il ya de nombreuses et ses nombreux
articles sur le sujet depuis quelques
années et depuis ces dernières mois
cette question répond réellement il ya
une attente nous constatons nous les
députés dans nos circonscriptions des
attentes importantes sur ce sujet donc
l'objectif alors l'interrogation que
j'ai porté au premier ministre et au
ministre de l'intérieur c'était de dire
qu'on était attaché évidemment nous à ce
que cette loi puisse être présenté le
plus rapidement possible puisque nous
l'attendons et il ya eu un certain
nombre de propositions mais qui ne se
sont encore jamais traduites pour des
questions de calendrier d'événements
nous avons connu ces derniers mois cette
question de du séparatisme de la montée
de l'islamisme politique comme l'a très
clairement dit le président de la
république n'a pas été encore inscrit à
l'ordre du jour là pour le coup nous
attendons un projet de loi pour le mois
de décembre avec un examen nous a dit le
ministre de l'intérieur avant une
première lecture avant les élections qui
devraient se tenir au mois de mars
l'objectif est très clair et sur lequel
nous allons pouvoir débattre au sein de
notre groupe il serait intéressant que
nous puissions aussi en débattre au sein
de notre parti c'est l'adaptation de la
loi de séparation de l'église et de
l'état c'est à dire la loi de 1905 c'est
l'adaptation de la loi de 1905 à la
poussée de l'intégrisme islamiste amélie
c'est à dire revoir et adapter le régime
des cultes donner des moyens notamment
renforcer le rôle des préfets dans
chaque département le rôle de contrôle
sur le financement le grohl de contrôle
également sur le recrutement des
ministres des cultes mais également
avoir les moyens les outils qu'ils n'ont
pas forcément actuellement pour
contrôler les phénomènes que nous
constatons et qui prend de l'ampleur les
phénomènes de déscolarisation mais
également la surveillance des écoles
hors contrat
ces écoles privées dont on sait qu'un
certain nombre ne respectent pas le
cahier des charges pour lequel ils
doivent s'engager auprès auprès de
l'état et auprès de l'éducation
nationale et enfin il ya un dernier
volet qui n'est pas forcément le plus
simple mais sur lequel on a bien vu
qu'il y avait également des dérives
c'est la question
des milieux sportifs la question du
recrutement des éducateurs sportifs donc
c'est des questions qui sont à la fois
très concrètes dans ce que va pouvoir
donner cette loi sur le séparatisme est
une autre question plus générale qui des
deux données pour notre majorité
un signal politique fort attendu je
crois des français et c'est ce que j'ai
tenté de réagir mais au premier ministre
mardi dernier car il ne faudrait pas
qu'une fois de plus cette loi pour
diverses raisons soit repoussée car je
crois que ça serait une erreur de ne pas
l'inscrire dans notre mandat avant 2022
voilà merci beaucoup je crois que c'est
extrêmement éclairant et c'est un sujet
qui va passionner au noble sens du terme
les français et qui aura évidemment un
enjeu un enjeu majeur
il nous reste 15 minutes pour cette
table ronde je voudrais alors mode petit
lève le doigt et juste après je passe la
parole à jean marie mode en deux minutes
jean-marie pour conduit sur le sénat
vraiment en deux minutes
je voudrais dire en fait que je fais
partie de la commission denquête
qu'ovide sur les impacts sur la jeunesse
et donc gt gt à l'audition lorsqu'il ya
eu vous avez vous en avez tous entendu
parler
l'intervention des collègues du groupe l
air et de la collègue de la république
en marche qui ont souhaité quitter les
auditions parce qu'une jeune femme
représentante de bénef s'était présentée
intégralement enfin voilà quoi
j'ai été relativement déranger je le
cache pas j'ai été vraiment dérangé
parce qu'en fait moi j'ai une conception
de la femme qui est autre que celle là
et que je sais que dans le monde y ait
beaucoup de femmes qui se battent pour
ne plus avoir à porter le voile
mais j'ai écouté le discours de cette
jeune femme qui était relativement
intéressant c'est une femme qui était
très instruite qui nous a apporté
énormément d'éléments donc la question
qui se pose c'est que le problème qui se
pose c'est que il ya véritablement des
solutions à trouver et comme le disait
isabelle il faut absolument qu'on puisse
trouver des solutions d'ici à la fin du
mandat
parce que même pour ces personnes qui
portent le hijab en l'occurrence
finalement elle empêche parce qu'on les
entende
puisque tout le monde est parti alors
qu'elle avait quelque chose
d'intéressant à dire un certaines
personnes ont quitté la salle alors
qu'elle avait quelque chose
d'intéressant à dire
donc voilà je voulais juste faire ce
témoignage là pour dire qu'il faut qu'on
soit vigilant
peut-être qu'il faut qu'on soit amené à
des réflexions sur la révision des
règlements intérieurs de nos
institutions je ne sais pas c'est
véritablement des questionnements que
j'ai mais en tout cas je suis du même
avis qu isabelle il faut absolument pas
que le projet de loi soit reportée et
qu'on y travaille le plus rapidement
possible voilà merci hommes isabelle
voulait réagir également deux minutes
merci c'est difficile sur ce sujet de
faire court il faut brancher ton micro
isabelle sinon ça va être très court en
effet mais j'ai pas rebranchés oui juste
pour elle pour rebondir sur ce que vient
de dire mme houde et je savais pas qui
était à 7 à cette commission j'ai été
interrogé sur le sujet moi je suis
absolument d'accord avec toi la question
du voile c'est une question apparente
elle mais je voudrais pas une fois de
plus que le débat qui est d'ampleur qui
est large que nous devons porter sur la
montée de l'islam politique la lutte
contre le séparatisme toutes ces
questions qui vont bien au delà de la
question du voile parce qu'une fois de
plus on a bien vu les médias et ses
députés confisquer ce débat ça jt agité
les choses politiquement pour réduire le
débat à la question ou non du pôle du
port du voile qui en cela est autorisé
de toute façon est autorisée est
autorisé dans
les lieux publics donc revenir par le
petit bout de la lorgnette sur un
problème qui est bien plus large
bien plus majeur pour notre pays je
trouve ça serait dommage qu'il faut et
tu as eu raison un mode de rester et de
ne pas te laisser tenter par par cccc
effet gérer médiatique de ses députés
parce que je pense qu'il faut une fois
de plus et c est notre groupe en sera je
l'espère et j'en ai pas de doute porteur
d'une discussion qui doit être apaisée
et qui doit être un échange qu'on peut
porter au sein de l'assemblée nationale
qui doit être fructueux mais je dirais
pas comme il a été une fois de plus
abordé c'est à dire conflictuel parce
que de ce conflit ne naîtra rien une
fois de plus sur ce sujet donc voilà
juste pour clore sur ce débat merci
fabien 6 merci beaucoup isabelle
effectivement les débats sur cette loi
vont être extrêmement important je
voudrais passer la parole à jean marie
on est à sept jours d'une élection
sénatoriale
alors de deux questions en une on nous
dit que le paysage ne serait pas
sensiblement bouleversé par cette
élection alors tu vas pas nous donner
les résultats ans j'en suis sûr mais
elle est donc bon sentiment et puis être
une question pour illustrer ou en tout
cas décrire les rapports du sénat avec
l'exécutif est maman avec le président
mais avec l'exécutif dont on a vu qu'ils
pouvaient être conflictuelle
je pense que les pronostics sont
aujourd'hui facile à faire avec le sénat
puisqu'on a un corps électoral qui est
relativement mesurable avec depuis
l'élection des maires temps évidemment
il ya trois mois donc on sait qu'ils ont
quand même beaucoup de bouleversements
la majorité restera la majorité composée
à la fois du groupe et l'air et de
l'union centriste
ça fait à peu près 100 90 je pense qu'il
y aura beaucoup de changements ni dans
le groupe et leur leader centriste
peut-être quelques des faits
malheureusement et quelques départs
aussi c'est normal qu'ils aient les gens
qui ne se représente pas ils seront
remplacés dans les savanes le mans par
des personnes de la même formation
et puis oui avant quelques
bouleversements chez les à la haine
parce qu'il ya la moitié de la haine qui
est en renouvellement et sur les 23 qui
composent le groupe
si les pronostics 10 qui en appellerait
ça qui pourrait effectivement ou voire
plus qui pourraient même ton le reste le
rdse aussi c'est à dire les radicaux des
radicaux de gauche pour l'essentiel
risque aussi de souffrir de ce scrutin
mais donc voilà grande stabilité
une majorité qui reste en place autour
raisonnablement du président larcher
les centristes continueront à vos dépôts
dans l'axé je rappelle que parmi les
centristes qui a une dizaine de modèles
va pas rater
chez nous il y en a cinq qui sont un
renouvellement 3 mon avis ne pose pas
beaucoup de problèmes en a deux qui sont
vraiment menacé instances notamment
alain cazabonne et un à michel julia et
nous les soutenons évidemment à fond
donc
[Musique]
tu parlais fabien des enjeux j'exige
qu'ils sont un petit peu artificiel
monsieur le corps nu
à ce prix là il a été assez médiatique
mais est ce réel de pensée bien réaliste
plutôt de penser aujourd'hui alors qu'on
est pas moins très lues et entendues
dans leur est bien réaliste de penser à
l'élection président du président du
sénat pour la prochaine fois et de
vouloir pour ce fait assembler tous ceux
qui soutiennent le président de la
république
je crois que le sénat mais c'est sa
marque de fabrique c'est d'avoir la
capacité de constituer des majorités
l'idée c'est pas la première fois qu'on
arrive à partir d'assemblée clips sont
en apparence pas favorable à la majorité
présidentielle est loin d'avoir un
obtenir un vote favorable sur un certain
nombre de sujets très importants on le
cas récemment eu il ya un an quand il
s'est agit par exemple de la loi santé
on a eu aussi par exemple sur un groupe
centriste qui est partagé la moitié du
mot qui a voté la confiance à el ouahch
kribi que d'envoyer je pense qu'on aime
capacités au sénat à dépasser les
conflits d'étiquettes si je dirais pour
essayer d'aller à l'essentiel pour ça
j'attends moi que les députés
l'assemblée nationale d'une façon
générale soient très attentives aussi
aux propositions du sénat je crois que
la force du parlement
c'est pas effectivement d'avoir un vote
positif
suivant en conforme ou pas très éloigné
les positions du gouvernement à
l'assemblée
c'est d'essayer de rassembler une
majorité de parlementaires députés et
sénateurs
sur des projets de loi auquel nous
tenons et sur des compositions qui
amendent réellement profondément parfois
le les projets qu'il allait manquer par
exemple on va voir et tout à l'heure
patrick faisait allusion la loi
dépendance daloa autonomie ont évité et
dénonce cette loi est une loi pour moi
capital fondamental qui va être la
pierre d'angle de la réélection du
président de l'arrivée dans la tête pas
tout à fait conscience mais c'est je
dirais et des millions et des millions
de personnes aussi bien les personnes
âgées que ceux qui sont les aidants qui
sont concernés et donc est en général ce
sont des électeurs et donc je dirais que
si on a véritablement une approche comme
c'est le cas parce que ça va être que
premier du gouvernement qui va poser sur
la table un projet de loi avec
effectivement des mesures concrètes et
un financement ne passe sur le rapport
de monsieur h et qui ne absolument pas
responsable si j'ose dire faire un
catalogue de toutes les mesures qu'on
est en droit de prendre pour trouver le
financement
c'est pas ce qu'on attendait d'eux on
l'attendait c'était des orientations
le gouvernement se trouve avec un
catalogue mais saches tout le monde
était capable de le faire je dirais en
mai j'ai donc il va falloir
effectivement au niveau du parlement
nous inventions le financement et il
manque effectivement 8 à 10 millions mi
des arts pardon d'ici 2024 et 2030
donc qui rafla que nous trouvions ses
sources de financement j'attends j'ai
quelques idées évidemment tant que
rapporteur général sous ses possibilités
il ya notamment beaucoup d'économies à
faire dans l'assurance maladie parce que
beaucoup de soin sont renault d'armes
inutiles
il ya beaucoup d'économies a fait en
juin
la fraude aux prestations sociales et
aussi aux cotisations donc il ya un
vaste champ d'action pour le parlement
merci jean marie parle moi de devoir
interrompre on arrive presque à la fin
donc je voudrais qu'on n'a pas trop
parlé du sénat donc je dis scrupules at
interrompre haut mais je voudrais si son
mari je voudrais vraiment que frédéric
petit avant de laisser conclure patrick
le président du groupe nous dise un mot
du bélarus qui se passe au bélarus aux
portes de l'europe
je n'en dis pas plus frédéric mais merci
d'abord devenir le bélarus je vous
invite tous à ne pas utiliser le mot
biélorussie qu'est le bélarus est le nom
officiel de ce pays
voilà alors je pense que tout le monde
suit c'est vrai que moi j'ai été sa
défaite ça ne fait pas partie de ma
circonscription
mais à deux idées que je que je porte ce
parce a d'abord je voudrais la vente et
au reste de l'europe à mieux comprendre
cette région qui est une région très
très particulière une région qu'on
appelle dans l'est dans toutes les
langues de la pologne à l'ukraine et
c'est qu'on appelle de la mer du nord à
la mer noire et qui est une région qui a
été historiquement un grand d'europe
non c'est à dire au moment du royaume
des deux couronnes ce qu'on appelait la
république des deux couronnes c'est un
c'est un territoire on a du mal à
comprendre ça parce que nous on a une
vision de la république qui est
différente en france et en allemagne
aussi c'est un endroit où vivaient six
ou sept nations en mêlée avec des
institutions qui se croisaient qui
étaient des nations qui pouvait vivre en
paix pendant des siècles qui pouvait le
du jour au lendemain d'un ventes et des
programmes c'est eux qui ont inventé ce
mot et esi gouhier y compris le beau
frère s'il beau frère faisait partie de
l'autre de l'autre nation
voilà donc la première idée que je
voudrais c'est c'est ramener ce qui se
passe au bélarus aujourd'hui c'est une
recherche d'identité sûr que tout d'un
coup cette ce pays qui a été un pays qui
a été à l'origine de la russie les
moscovites s'étaient des bélarusses qui
était parti à eau le tout d'un coup se
repose la question mais qui on est et ce
n'est pas une volonté d'adhérer à
l'union européenne ce n'est pas ce qui
s'est passé en ukraine il ya aucun enjeu
économique
que le bélarus reste ralliés à la russie
économiquement parce que les gens par le
russe quand ils font des affaires
moi j'ai trahi et j'y suis allé deux
fois une fois en 2003 en 2015 c'est un
pays c'était une république soviétique
qui marchait un peu mieux que les autres
c'est un pays qui a connu une
augmentation du niveau de vie depuis 30
ans voilà ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est un fait c'est ce que j'explique
saillir sur une recherche d'identité
le deuxième le deuxième caisse deuxième
idée que je que je véhicule à ce sujet
c'est que l'europe doit avoir une
frontière
nos frontières c'est une idée
fondamentale c'est une des éducatifs ses
études et pédagogique et il faut que de
lisbonne à varna est à copenhague on ait
la même idée de wes qu on est
responsable on a parlé beaucoup
d'écologie il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas de politique qui colle écologique
ici on n'est pas si on n'a pas de
frontières ont personne ne peut sauver
la planète mais on doit sauver ce qui
est chez soi donc jusqu'où on est chez
nous jusqu'au on n'est pas chez nous
c'est important pour l'écologiste
important pour la langue c'est important
pour la culture est pour moi le bélarus
et au delà ma frontières européennes
c'est clair je connais bien ces régions
la pologne et le belarus n'est pas par
contre c'est un voisin
voilà et donc l'europe à une politique
de voisinage et c'est en ça que ça nous
concerne c'est un voisin sur lequel on
peut s'appuyer sur lequel on peut avoir
des l'europe a monté une politique ce
qu'elle appelle une politique de
voisinage est fait avec ça qu'il faut
qu'il faut c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
qu'il faut s'appuyer
voilà j'ai été j'ai eu l'honneur de
discuter avec les tirs à la scala
pendant une demi-heure au forum un show
rome politico-économique la semaine
dernière en pologne 7
c'est impressionnant de voir elle nous
ressemble au modèle en fait cette femme
parce qu'elle a fait irruption politique
elle a soutenu son mari un moment je dis
c'est comme moi mais pas tout à fait
plein de détritus sont beaucoup plus
dramatique mais est arrivé en politique
parce qu'elle a senti qu'elle était
appelée qu'il fallait qu'elle se lève
avec n'diaye
elle a pas envie d'y rester ne crois pas
que c'est elle qui l'a je crois que la
solution sera un compromis mais que ça
sera pas et qu'il portera
plus tôt la touche corps et voilà ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est ce que le
compromis aura lieu après une explosion
de violences par m l'issue de la crise
est assez imprévisible tu te dis toi
même frédéric mais l'éclairage que tu
nous donnais est intéressant parce qu'il
nous permet de dépasser un petit peu le
simple question de la crise actuelle
merci beaucoup on arrive au terme de
cette rencontre une heure et demie c'est
très court mais je vais laisser patrick
mignola le président du groupe conclure
je laissais conclure sur cette belle
formule de jean william dans les
commentaires qui a dit tout à l'heure
alliée mais pas aligné oui c'est
exactement notre travail dans la
majorité présidentielle il faut que
cette majorité soit soit riche de cette
diversité et on sait être divers mais
évidemment loyaux à chaque fois que
c'est nécessaire
merci beaucoup fabien pour avoir animé
ce moment allier aligner je n'ajouterai
quelque chose d'aussi sérieux on vient
de le prouver pendant une heure et demie
parce que les inférences le député de
très grande qualité je les en remercie
également
et puis amis et parce qu'on est amis je
voudrais juste pour le mot de la fin
avoir une pensée pleine d'affection pour
marielle de sarnez qui ne pouvait pas
participer à cette à cette vision avec
nous mais on pense très fort elle est
évidemment on embrasse merci beaucoup
cher président écoute et on arrive au
terme de cette rencontre je crois qu'on
a tous bien senties l'authenticité la
qualité la richesse et la vraie plus
value que représente le groupe modem et
apparentés à l'assemblée nationale merci
beaucoup
à bientôt